أنا متحمس جدًا لما
حدث خلال العقد الماضي أو نحو ذلك
فيما يتعلق بفن غرب آسيا وشمال
إفريقيا، حيث كانت هناك مبيعات قياسية،
لذا فإن الأرقام هي إحدى الطرق لقياس
الاهتمام بالناس، ولكن كان هناك أيضًا
اهتمام قياسي من قبل المتاحف في جميع أنحاء العالم.  أيها
العالم، من الرائع أن
يعترف بقية العالم بفننا ولكن
ما يهم حقًا هو أن شبابنا
يعترفون بفننا، لقد استثمرت
ما يبدو وكأنه عمر كامل في دعم
الفن والفنانين من هذه المنطقة، يتم
وصفك
بشكل مختلف على أنك جامع أعمال فنية  أكاديمي
كفنان وكاتب كموصل، كيف
تصف نفسك؟ أود أن
أصف نفسي ربما كشخص
يحب منطقته، شخص
يؤمن بإمكانيات
منطقته، ويؤمن بأننا نستحق
الأفضل، وحماسك لهذه
المنطقة هو  معدي لقد قلت في
الماضي إن كل ما تريد
رؤيته هو هذه المنطقة وشبابها
مسلحون بفرش الرسم والأقلام ماذا تقصد بذلك
قلت في
مقابلة أنه يجب علينا تسليح الشباب
وفكرت أمي  أنني أقصد
أنواعًا مختلفة من الأسلحة،
أعتقد حقًا أنك تعرف فرشاة
الرسم، القلم والورق،
الميكروفون، هذه هي الأسلحة، هذه هي الطرق
التي ننشر بها ونعبر بها عن
أنفسنا ولذا فنحن حقًا في
معركة مع بقية العالم
حيث نحتاج إلى التأكد من
عدم غرق أصواتنا، نحتاج إلى
التأكد من أن الشباب في
منطقتنا لديهم الوسائل
والإمكانية والقدرة على مشاركة
أفكارهم ومشاركة أعمالهم الفنية
من خلال عرضها في المتاحف  شارك
موسيقاهم والمقطوعات التي تراها
خلال السنوات الماضية غالبًا ما تشاهدها
من خلال سجن الصراع سلطان
دائمًا هذه المقطوعة الرائعة التي
نجلس أمامها هنا وبدأت
في عام 2004 كما أفهمها بعد
حرب العراق مباشرة  هل حان الوقت للانتقال من ما تم
النقر عليه،
لا أعتقد ذلك، لذلك أعتقد أننا كشرق
أوسطيين، نحن كأشخاص
معاصرين لهذه المنطقة، نحتاج
إلى أن نعكس ما يحدث في هذا الجزء
من العالم، فلا يمكنك تجاهل
اللاجئين فحسب  أزمة أزمة تغير المناخ
أزمة البطالة، هناك الكثير من
الأزمات التي نعيشها
بينكم، لا يمكننا تجاهلها فحسب، فهل
نرى انهيار خطيئة المحرمات في
الفن العربي والإيراني الحديث والمعاصر،
حسنًا، أعتقد أن هناك محرمات
نحن قادرون على الاستكشاف وأعتقد
بطريقة ذكية أه المحرمات الجنسية على سبيل
المثال يمكن استكشافها المحرمات الدينية
يمكن استكشافها للأسف في هذا
الجزء من العالم المحرمات السياسية هي
التي تقلق الحكومات أكثر
لأنها على سبيل المثال لا
تفعل ذلك  "لا أريد أن أرى أي تحديات
لسلطتهم، لذا فأنا
أتعاطف مع الفنانين الذين لديهم كل
هذه الخطوط الحمراء التي يتعين عليهم
مواجهتها ولكن في نفس الوقت
يمكن للفنانين الأذكياء أن يكونوا أذكياء إلى درجة
يمكنهم من خلالها فهم وجهة نظرهم"  عبر دون إثارة
غضب الديني، العائلي،
المجتمعي، الاجتماعي، السياسي،
والسؤال الأخير، ما أنت أو من
أكثر ما أنت متحمس له في الوقت الحاضر في
عالمك حول أوه واو بيكي، أنا
متحمس لنوع الجنس أكثر من أنا
متحمس لـ  أنا متحمس
بشأن إمكانيات تسليط
الضوء على الفنانات من
منطقتي. أنا متحمس لنادية صقالي. أنا
متحمس لماريا. أنا متحمس. أنا
متحمس لكامالا.. أنا
متحمس.
يا فتى، يمكنني الاستمرار.  لذلك أنا متحمس
للفنانات، وهذا هو المكان الذي يوجد فيه
قلبي، وهذا هو المكان الذي يتواجد فيه ذهني،
وهذا هو ما أحلم بالمضي قدمًا به،
وهناك العديد من المعارض التي
تسلط الضوء على الفن النسائي وأعتقد حقًا
أن هذا هو التالي  الحدود
بالنسبة لنا في الشرق الأوسط